justice est sur le bord du gouffre le
constat de la batonnière du Québec est
alarmant la principale cause de la crise
qui s'en vient c'est le sous-financement
du système de justice au Québec dans les
palais de justice il manque de greffiers
d'agent de sécurité et de jus encore
plus depuis la décision de la juge en
chef de la Cour du Québec de modifier
l'horaire des juges pour qu'ils passent
moins de temps en salle de cours et plus
en délibération étant donné la
complexité des causes récentes le droit
à évoluer dans les dernières années qui
qui pour la juge en chef justifierait
un ratio de délibéré de 1 pour 1 ceci
dit je ne fais que vous exposez les
faits je ne prends pas position le
ministre Simon Gelin barrette lui a
choisi son camp après avoir dénoncé
cette décision unilatérale de la cour il
dit à être en mode solution moi chouvard
a donné des ressources supplémentaires à
donner des jeux supplémentaires
effectivement mais faut que ça se
traduise par un gain d'efficacité on
fera pas uniquement ajouter des
ressources pour avoir les mêmes
résultats c'est pas acceptable pas
acceptable parce que les délais
explosent déjà avec la décision de la
Cour du Québec
ça rend le travail de tous encore plus
difficile les impacts se font sentir
jusqu'à coup de joie ou cet avocat de
Montréal se rendent sporadiquement juste
matin j'ai vu un procès être reporté un
homme détenu Inuit
en nous 203 on est en novembre il me
fait présumé innocent le ministère de la
Justice du Québec évalue à 50000 le
nombre de dossiers en 2023 qui sont à
risque d'être abandonnés en raison de
délais déraisonnable les personnes
victimes vont sentir que
leur vécu et moi important
qu'on invalide les conséquences de la
violence qu'il ou elles ont vécu le
Directeur des poursuites criminels
Épinal assure qu'il va prioriser les
dossiers de violence sexuelle de
violences conjugales si les délais se
poursuivent car le danger avec l'arrêt
des procédures c'est de miner la
confiance du public envers le système de
justice ici jacauderie Charbonneau
Radio-Canada montré